[Music]
it's among the most profitable car
makers in the world
yet in 2013 this french car maker was
facing bankruptcy
since then its new chief executive has
achieved a remarkable turnaround
and then done it again across the border
in germany
this is bloomberg turnaround join me to
see how carlos tavares put psa peugeot
citroen
back in the race
[Music]
it's a source of pride for the nation uh
and also it's showing up that
the manufacturing business in france is
not over hello
i met the man who was one of europe's
most influential car executives
at his paris headquarters
five years ago you were facing a
near-death experience so we need
to keep on being agile we understand how
important it is to move around the
roadblocks
and
the more chaotic the world around us is
the more agility is an asset for a
company like ours
psa owns the brands peugeot citroen ds
automobile opel and voxel
in 2018 the combined group reported
record earnings and its auto unit made a
return on sales of 7.6
rivaling its german peers
profit was driven by sales of the
european car of the year the peugeot
3008 suv
[Music]
the record result was also helped by
opel voxel which psa bought from general
motors in 2017
and turned around after two decades of
losses
psa was really on its knees they lost
eight billion dollars over two years
most industry ex observers had counted
them out they were too slow and then
carlos tavares came in and in the matter
of a few years took out a lot of cost
improved efficiency improved asset
structure
tavares turnaround formula was called
back in the race
cut the number of models in each brand
make more profit on each
reduce the numbers of platforms they're
made on
and cut costs
everywhere
it was capable to
convince all the people that the number
of models they used to have in the group
was not fiddling with the market
requirements
and so
reducing the the manufacturing
complexity
uh was about to revamp
the product lineup and it was very hard
to convince them to do that because
obviously it's affecting um the the
organization around the plants and
obviously the reducing the cost
was a bit painful
[Music]
key was the repositioning of brands that
had been confusing customers
ds on top
peugeot in the middle
and citroen the value proposition
we want to focus the creative energy of
the company on a more limited number of
products completely aligned with the
expectations of the markets in which we
operate
the transformation can be seen in the
share price reaching a low at the end of
2012 at the depth of the crisis
since tavares appointment was announced
at the end of 2013 the shares have more
than doubled
[Music]
psa has been transforming itself for
years
i visited peugeot's birthplace at social
in eastern france where the vast plants
is being modernised
the peugeot brothers started a rolling
steel mill in 1810 making saws coffee
pepper and salt grinders even cages for
crinoline dressers
so one of the things they branched out
into was to make penny farthing bicycles
but they were also making carriages and
cuts that needed horses and then the
idea came up to the brothers peugeot
what if we put an engine in front of our
carriage
fast forward to the second half of the
20th century and peugeot was one of the
most prestigious industrial jewels in a
resplendent france
making cars for a growing middle class
the 1970s it bought citroen which was
struggling and psa peugeot citroen was
born
[Music]
but by the time the global financial
crisis hit in 2008 the company had
become unwieldy producing too many
models on too many platforms with brands
that confused consumers
between july 2007 and the end of 2008
the share price dropped more than 80
percent
the company was burning through billions
peugeot needed outside help
by 2013 talks started for the french
state and china's dongfeng motor to buy
14
each
for the family to halve its holdings
and carlos tavares was appointed
[Music]
tavares started his career in 1981 as a
test driver at renault
by 2011 he was renault's chief operating
officer second only to carlos cone
then came the bloomberg interview
in which tavares laid out his personal
ambitions it was really surprising
actually because here you have somebody
who is the right-hand man for renault
nissan which was a very successful
company at the time didn't have any of
the problems that you see today
essentially saying i'd really like to
become a ceo and if i have to leave my
current company to do it i will
he didn't last much longer at renault
after that
no matter by the end of 2013 he was
appointed to the top job at peugeot
a month after assuming the ceo position
tavares announced his turnaround plan
back in the race
he's a ruthless cost cutter and he's had
to be and that's why peugeot has margins
at a similar level to the likes of bmw
over the past year although some of that
is to do with restructuring charges and
just experience you know he's been in
the industry a long time
[Music]
i'm on the evidence rma in paris if you
look up the end there you can see the
arc de triomphe that means we're in
central paris
now if you look over here you can see
the former headquarters of the psa group
i say former headquarters because carlos
tavares moved the headquarters to the
suburbs
much cheaper
all part of the cost-cutting drive
the new headquarters is at ruel
malmeisen about eight miles from the
centre of paris
coming up we'll take a look at how
tavares known for asking colleagues to
switch off office lights
injected a cost-cutting culture into the
company and to get more from the man
himself we started from a very simple
recognition which was that
if we are in trouble it's not because
we're not working enough
we are working like hell
[Music]
in his five years at the helm
carlos tavares has managed to return not
just persia citroen to profitability but
the german car maker opel as well
the interesting thing is that we've got
french cars coming off the production
line
and german cars coming off the same
production line the peugeot 3008 and
opel's grand land x
two quite distinct cars
[Applause]
[Music]
when tavares first visited socho his
message was clear
the first time that mr tavares came we
were in the body shop he sees the body
shop manager and he asks what is your
added value what is the return on
investment of this workshop and the
manager stood there completely stupefied
because that wasn't something we were
used to working with
today that has completely changed we
have changed the culture because
effectively today from the manager to
the operator we think about the cost
price we know that we have to be
competitive with countries where prices
are lower
how did you go about
selling your vision to the workforce
it was not
very sophisticated it was quite
simplistic to a certain extent you see
people when i came to the psa group in
december 2013 were working like hell
they were working 12 hours a day
eventually more
and the more they work
the more the results were read
so we started from a very simple
recognition which was that
if we are in trouble it's not because
we're not working enough
we are working like hell
[Music]
one of the early challenges was to bring
france's unions into the fold
it's very difficult in europe to
take people out of the workforce
and you've got to remember that peugeot
took quite a hefty subsidy during the
financial crisis
to save the company they had a three
billion rights issue as well but they
were very close to going bankrupt so i
think the unions accepted that they had
to cut costs
and it's done being done through natural
attrition as well but you know he's
certainly taking people and a lot of
costs out of the business
carlos tavares was capable to build up
an alliance with the poor reform trade
unions and uh just after a couple of
years uh it was it's crazy because
all the political driven trade unions
are reduced to silence uh because for
instance recently
everyone was granting a significant
bonus in the film and so it's not
possible for these trade unions to uh to
speak anymore but would the unions
become more difficult as psa group
becomes more profitable with the five
unions i have in my company representing
80
of my people
they have signed all the strategic plans
all the performance plans and they have
been one of the big supporters of this
profitability improvement that we have
delivered over the five years i think
they understand that
this is a this is a race you see it is
it is a competitive game that we are
facing every day
i asked this question to my unions um in
december 2018 and i told them look guys
we are we are profitable our situation
is very good
i can hear here or there some tensions
and some
small issues i don't want those issues
to grow and i ask my unions should i
ease a little bit on the accelerated
pedal
and my unions told me no way president
don't do that keep it flat out
the back in the race targets were met
two years early heralding the next stage
of tavares's plan back in the race and
its operational excellence outcome
is the foundation
on which we are going to put
the strategic profitable growth plan
that we have called push to class while
back in the race was about restructuring
and weeding out underperforming models
push to pass shifted the focus to
expansion as tavares pushed to compete
with bigger rivals
psa gets about 80 percent of its revenue
from the european market where
automakers face a consumer slowdown and
eu emissions regulations are
accelerating the adoption of electric
cars
sales in china are also a problem
sinking by a third last year making the
car maker even more reliant on the
wobbly european market
that explains its goal to increase sales
outside europe by 50 percent by 2021.
first one will bring the peugeot brand
to the us and a canadian market second
one will bring situate to the indian
market and third one will bring the opel
branch to the russian market those are
the three big announcements on which we
are putting our energy and our focus to
get there tavares expects his staff to
go
the extra mile
this is this concept of the extra mile
that you talk about
where if one person fails because
everyone's doing the extra mile if you
manage the team only on the fact that
we cannot fail
and we have a very ambitious goal
then you are just adding
tension stress in the organization
and you are not giving anybody the
possibility to fail because if somebody
fails and the and the team loses
as a result of an individual failure
then that that person will be in trouble
which means that if you want to
keep the possibility for each of your
team members to fail
and at the same time
the team needs to win
means each team member needs to go one
extra mile beyond his own objective
to cover the risk that
among one of those team members there
will be one that can fail and that's
very normal because he's a human being
you spoke to bloomberg in 2013 and you
were talking about how you would like
you were at renault still okay and you
were talking about how you'd like to be
the leader of maybe ford or general
motors so you've been thinking about
being material for a chief executive for
quite some time where does your
self-belief come from possibly from the
fact that
since i was a teenager i was immediately
passionate about cars and and then i
became a mechanical engineer
start working
for a car maker at that point in time it
was renault then went to nissan overseas
japan
in the united states
and i i love this industry it's such a
highly competitive industry because
there are many many contradictory things
it's a capital intensive
profitability is not very high the
number one guy in industry is making ten
percent profitability which is not such
a big number now there was an interview
in uh lizeko a french newspaper and my
office is abuzz with one part of the
interview the fact that you're at home
at seven o'clock every night having
dinner with your wife is that true every
every night when i'm working here yes
and that's the reason why you have so
much time pressure on this interview
all right because yes yeah that's
because you've got to get home by seven
o'clock yeah are you trying to show a
new example for france
i'm trying to show you that
we are here to get results
not to make ours
and that's very very important you know
it happens to me
to tell some of my top executives
that they are working too much
it happened i said to one of them say
hey
i'm worried
you seem tired
you travel too much
and your working days are too long and
that's not good i want you to keep some
bandwidth
where you can step back
look at the talent management and not be
always trying to solve the operational
issue every minute
the acquisition of opel gave psa group a
lot of heft when it comes to scale
but is it enough to fund the autonomous
vehicle development as well as to
accelerate the switch to electric
by the end of this year for example psa
has pledged that each model developed by
its brands will have an electric or
hybrid version you have to be very agile
if not even darwinian which means if you
don't change you disappear
[Music]
opel is the latest automaker to benefit
from the carlos tavares turnaround touch
psa bought the germany based company
from general motors alongside uk brand
vauxhall in 2017
his task now is to further integrate the
companies to save more money while
driving vital investments for the future
[Music]
well as we move into new areas such as
the transition uh to electric vehicles
and also autonomous driving you need
scale there's huge investments that have
been undertaken by the car makers at the
moment and one thing that peoria didn't
have before opel was significant scale
so the addition of opal gives them scale
they're now at close to four million
units and that allows these additional
costs for new technologies to be divided
over a wider
product
base opel lost nearly 20 billion dollars
over two decades
[Music]
after a year of tavares at the helm it
reported profit of nearly a billion
dollars in 2018.
one horsepower and basically the first
car of opel tavares tapped michael lowe
schiller chief financial officer at opal
to head up the division
tavares he says changed the way opel
thought about making cars just as he'd
done at peugeot citroen
the key point from my perspective was a
new mindset mindset really focused on
performance and implementing things
and then he also gave us a lot of
freedom
for the important things of the business
in particular design
and the positioning of our brands opel
and voxer
the big challenge at opel was how to
make low margin cars in a high cost
country
profitably
low sheller got unions to agree to
eliminate nearly 4 000 jobs through
buyouts
then there was a drive to reduce
manufacturing complexity
one of our car lines had 27 different
steering wheels
but customers were not asking for 27
different steering wheels so we brought
this down to eight and that is one
tangible example and we have many many
more where actually we reduce complexity
without jeopardizing our customer offer
because obviously the customer is in the
focus of everything we do
but it helped us to improve the
efficiency because complexity is an
enormous cross driver
to get a better idea of what a german
car should be
i met with the design director who
showed me the opel gtx experimental
concept car
[Music]
we are a german brand and german
precision is certainly something which
is ingrained in german engineering and
also in a certain kind in german design
and that also is something which helps
us to separate the brands within the psa
group with the three
french ones and then the british one and
the german one into two different
directions which is great and you can
see it at the car i believe so tell me
what i should be looking at when i'm
looking at the the german precision over
here well very clearly i think this very
proud this this bold face we call it the
visor which is
encompassing all the technical elements
and actually what we call it it's a
techno hub all the high-tech elements
like radar lidar all these elements are
kind of inside of the visor i noticed we
don't have any door handles since this
is a show car yeah a concept car what we
do is we open up the whole site and
we'll see it in a second once we open it
so the whole side of the vehicle opens
up
[Music]
despite initial success at opel psa
faces formidable headwinds
the big question is still about scale
and how to fund the huge investments
needed to develop electric vehicles
self-driving cars and mobility services
he's been successful with his suvs over
the last couple of years this is the
fastest growing segment going forward uh
the fastest growing segment will be
electric vehicles and because tavares
cut back significantly on r d and capex
over the past four or five years which
has boosted his free cash flow will he
have the technical ability to compete
with its peers
as opposed to just competing on price
because their cars aren't as technically
advanced as as the likes of the
competition so once again when it looks
to coming to making deals and alliances
then for tavares that would make sense
if they went to someone who already had
some sort of pretty significant uh
electric car technology that's correct
and if you look at the german
manufacturers since the financial crisis
they've made great success of their
sales in china the turnaround in europe
as well and that's allowed them to build
their balance sheets and they have very
strong
cash within their balance sheets and
that's allowed them to invest heavily in
electric vehicles and autonomous
vehicles over the past two or three
years that hasn't necessarily been the
case for peugeot because it's had to you
know cut back in these areas to bring
its cash flow back up to
where we would expect
for a european car company
[Music]
just this year psa is said to have been
in talks with fiat chrysler and jaguar
land rover being bigger may not help the
maneuverability of the company
you have to be very agile if not even
darwinian which means if you don't
change you disappear so in that
direction you don't want to be bigger
you want to be very compact very agile
very darwinian on the other side if you
have a significant change in the
regulations that imposes on you
very significant investments
which are going of course to be a burden
for your for your midterm plan and for
your profitability which is exactly what
we have here that may be one of the
reasons why you would like to share this
burden with other companies and have a
volume scale effect and sharing the
burden of those r d
investments that may be a reason on the
other side this is our attitude we are
as you mentioned we are too small
to have the leisure of not considering
opportunities i think that would be
counterproductive so yes we are open but
we are not targeting any specific
company or entity just because we have a
strong balance sheet we are highly
profitable we have the technology to
face electrification we are developing
our autonomous technology so
why should we look for that as
a simple goal it is not a goal it is an
opportunity if it comes on the table
in the past five years tavares with the
turnaround at peugeot and opal has
resurrected two struggling car makers
he now finds himself at the center of a
rapidly changing auto landscape as the
biggest players talk mergers and
alliances it's an arena he clearly
relishes
and this is why i think the period we
are living from now up to 2030 is going
to be absolutely exciting and despite
the chaos i'm very very excited i think
this this pressure we have these
disruptions we have are going to create
breakdowns in the eastern industry and
that means that opportunities will be
will be there on the table
[Music]